- So you have a certain party trick though
that Sabrina's not fond of.
(Idris chuckles)
So what's this party trick?
- Um...
(Kelly laughs)
- I feel like the all boys school's
about to come out right now.
- A hundred percent.
No, my party trick is that I love making
so I have a scatatonic sense of humor.
Does anyone know what that means?
- A scatatonic?
- [Idris] Sense of humor.
- You're like Pee-wee Herman right now
with Word of The Day.
- I know, right? Scatatonic.
- I don't know, yeah.
It means that, you know, when
someone does a fart joke.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay.
- Okay, you just can't stop laughing.
- I am into fart jokes
I think that's funny.
- Yeah, me too, right?
- So, uh and
so this is my party trick.
(farting sound)
(audience laughs)
- And it just slides.
(squeaks)
- You know what I'm saying.
- Oh my God!
( audience laughs)
- It's being able to
do it without you know
your eyebrows have got to stay still.
You gotta look really just
(squeaks)
- My favorite part is the slide up.
- Slide, it's the slide up.
- [Kelly] It's all about that slide.
- It's the slide up.
You know, when I'm acting you know
and you know, the countdown is like
"Okay, turn it over."
"Speed, camera and.."
(squeaks)
(Kelly laughs)
(audience applauding)
- "Action."
Just try to keep a straight face.
- That's never not funny.
Oh my God, you know
you're working with like
a really talented individual
when they don't break.
It's like...
(Idris chuckles)